pas sûr
hier aux allures de propagande plats
typiques ou encore robe traditionnelle a
essayé tout ici est estampillé corée du
nord qui dans ce bar de séoul
les clients sont venus chercher un petit
frisson nord-coréen tout comme la
majorité des sud coréens
le propriétaire n'a lui-même jamais
franchi la frontière mais il s'est
inspiré de l'imagerie du nord
comme cet écriteau sur lequel est écrit
peloton d'exécution pour toute personne
qui fumerait à l'intérieur le pion en
bar séduit de nombreux sud coréens mais
aussi quelques rares réfugiés venus du
nord pas sûr en revanche que le
pyongyang barre et bientôt son pendant
de l'autre côté de la zone démilitarisée